sylvain apporte son jonc de mariage chez
le bijoutier pour le faire réparer
les semaines passent sylvain n'a pas de
nouvelles du bijoutier
il découvre que la bijouterie a fait
faillite
sylvain n'en revient pas son projet de
mariage mais il voit les coordonnées du
syndic de faillite et reprend espoir
le syndic lui demande de remplir un
formulaire de réclamation pour qu'on
puisse l'identifier
il doit aussi prouver que la bague est
bel et bien à lui en lui présentant le
coupon de réparation ensuite il doit
faire la description de son bijou
la loi oblige les syndics de faillite a
séparé les biens du propriétaire et les
biens de ses clients
le syndic retrouve le jean et le rang
sylvain le fin mot de l'histoire
la faillite d'un commerçant non gouffre
pas les biens de ses clients